hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to resident evil village
also known as the game that i have been
looking forward to because of its
incredible gameplay
graphics detail and the level of quality
that you can expect from whoever the
hell made this game
there's no other reasons besides that
no other reasons at all
all right well i can't wait to go up and
find someplace warm hopefully like a
castle with
like a warm welcome huge knockers on the
doors
i am kind of questioning why i came out
did someone very tall just arrive home
that looks like a lovely castle i love
the buttresses
oh wait a minute what the hell
the white mineral found in this region
could probably sell it or i could gift
it to
someone what's
what's this what's this power i feel
resonating from this picture
yeah guys a man's dick is cut off in the
castle blah blah blah
hello remember from whence you came
i'll remember from whence i come
you are so kind to me daughters all
right
hey what's up hi now
let's take a look at him ah look at me
wow
well ethan winters yeah you escaped my
little brother's idiot games did you
oh yeah there's your brother huh let's
see how special you
are so special ow
that's my wound hand okay a little gross
very gross listen this is not a sexual
thing it's about power right
are these her gloves what power what is
that
the blood on the fruit what unique and
interesting tastes
dummy trask the very same
lady domitresque lady domitrisk
lady dimitrescu of the of the ducks
dugdale
demotress condom hello my lady oh
wait no lady come back lady come back no
not again
oh lady lady lady lady lady lady look at
me open the door you can obviously see
me come on
oh hi oh
all this for a child who isn't even here
what the hell do ah
[Music]
damn
rest while you
go ahead do your worst that's some
respectable
power right there the next day my auto
save was a little bit behind so i guess
we got to go through uh this
this scenario again god i've got to
watch through this again
who isn't even here yeah you know what
the hell do
how dare i indeed how dare i indeed
where the hell am i why am i able to
unlock it all from the inside
hey wow you got down here quick
ribbons okay
the power the power everybody the power
god you just gotta respect the level of
power that's
thundering down the halls
this is not a sexual thing it's about
power right oh
oh
[Music]
dammit rescue pretty good right
oh i would never shoot you i would never
shoot you my lady
hurry hurry hurry hurry hurry she's very
large very large
very powerful very powerful very large
okay
i mean god damn where are you oh wow you
are
so stay right there so chunk oh
you're sh you're so beautiful
oh you're so
beautiful maybe if i gave these all back
to lady didn't rescue she would be very
happy
you know maybe instead of daughters you
know
a son i'm just running out there hello
night not nice ass i respect its power
now
now see that's some power that i can
respect
don't be shy
my terror uh lady
we just met
i'm not sure that was actually related
to matriscu
[Music]
[Laughter]
drawbridge oh am i really done with the
castle oh
i mean i'll be back i'll be back of
course i'll be back now that we have
lady dimitrescu
with us at all times in our heart and in
my pocket which i'm still not entirely
sure how i fit the gigantic crystal
that is lady dimitrescu in my pocket it
will be
like i'm always in the dimitra rescue
dim a dome
i will take your delicious meat lady
dimitressko is hungry ladies
rescue wants to have a good dinner my
giveaway didn't
rescue what the lady wants
wife listen wife i met someone it's hard
to explain well it's easy to explain
she's twice your height
hey whoever is the master of this place
is not nearly as impressive as castle
dimitriscu not nearly a tall enough
doorways to
fit my magnificent grandeur i forgot
in the last episode to consult the
therapeutic
relaxing presence of where is she
where's where is she oh
this gonna die they took
my crystal imatrescu
all right i'm gonna kill you oh i can
leave now
do i have do i
examine now that that's comforting
this is what comfort feels like feels
like home
okay that's thirty nine thousand that's
a lot splendid
never no oh my hand i'm surprised i can
still use it
so soon after it got sliced off remember
the memories dimitresca dome
remember them fond memories we had
together
great memories incredible memories
the memories were great between you and
me
just such a short amount of time
together such great may maurice
i just gotta consult something real
quick here
[Music]
all right okay good and maybe if you
weren't so
actually disgusting you might impress
mama a bit more
okay now lady dimitrescu's someone that
you should draw inspiration from
she really was
[Music]
she was really something special oh
castle do my dress code
look babe look it's your castle
no no no look look
i missed castle dimitriscu i miss castle
till i trust you so much
oh the fond memories i have from those
times
i just miss it you know i just missed
castle's
least i got a snipey am i going back to
the castle
babe it's the back door into your place
babe
i yearn for the day when i open that up
again and it's lady dimitrescu waiting
for me to grab me by my throat
alright more
oh my lady
[Music]
my lady milady
all of them seem to be kind of chumps
except for lady dimitrescu she seemed to
be the strongest
most capable most beautiful evolving
really just respectable in every single
way i don't even care anymore i
care so much about you i would never
hurt you i'm not much for holding on to
things i don't i don't like to
be sentimental about nothing i say as i
keep crystal dimitriscu
[Music]
alcina dimitrescu cadoo affinity
most favorable brain functions normal an
unfit vessel for eva
that's because no al cena demetrescu
would ever be a vessel for someone
so unworthy as an eva already perfect is
what you were trying to say
already the pinnacle of evolution
literally could do no better so why
would you even need a vessel forever
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to what probably is the
final episode of resident evil
village i'm assuming this is where lady
demetrescu pops out of the woods
re-emerges in all of her glorious self
maybe nude
maybe not but i don't need it because
i'm tough and i got lady demetrisco on
my side
maybe we're gonna make it through this
if you believe in me
then i believe in you and i believe in
us i'm gonna get the models
would have been good for those sweet
thumbnails wait where's the image
[Music]
the power they're so respectable